so this is just a body reading drill
with me so he's gonna
throw stripes right through
okay come on okay and you're just gonna
hit
boom so don't go so fast that doesn't
start
[Music]
right
you can kind of absorb
okay okay so if
uh if i'm here he goes right look my lie
is different
so here's that stay there and this is
not where i throw that start
here
is boom i'm out of here not in here
out here okay and so that's right move
your hand out of the way
move all the way is that straight
so it's not going to be like this do you
see
it's got to go
you can do whatever boom you can see
move it away
right not like this same one
they gotta have a flight pot boom
i don't want that you see the same
flight path come back
right here boom out of the way
okay so not like this
don't worry about hitting his fist or
his arm he won't like either one
okay boom
so we'll do that one again see the elbow
again i don't know why someone was
throwing up will come out there but
let's say he did
and i checked this hand boom it's in
range i don't have to hit the hand
that's coming out i'm hitting this hand
move out of the way
boom attack that leg same thing
he goes i have to always clear the line
so i have to always clear the line
and then i always want the fight to
rotate so oh i'm
he's going to have to turn to face me
and the fight's rotating
so i don't want to put a line over here
you see
it's not much of a rotation the fight
hasn't started moving
so always keep it rotating oh he's gonna
face me again
and the fight's gonna be rotated
you got a couple choices here so i can
hit that knee joint
i can try for some motor dysfunction if
i hit deep enough in the thigh
okay but hit somewhere where this
thing's going to have an
effect on him then second or thirdly
go it's not his turn my turn
happens at the same time boom he strikes
the ice strike
you go not here then i go there
so he strikes boom
okay so let's just get in a situation so
keep it slow for now
and don't come in range of the stick
right away okay so you have to start
your attack from
there he comes in again i go boom
right and then he's gonna try to grab
the stick you got it i don't know if you
would hit it with the hand that i
hit well if you want to see
there you go okay and then you want to
engage there you go
okay got it right okay so we're gonna do
that one he did that one
so what did you throw
and he's going to charge me you want to
charge me you get it you want to smother
the stick
that's what i want to learn what to deal
with okay if you're going to stay out
there
right boom i'll just come in and beat
the out of you but you want to
smother the weapon
okay but i don't want you to freak out
so he goes
boom and he smothers the weapons mother
of the weapon got it
so i'm gonna find the outside
that's gonna be my strategy
so boom smothers the weapon i find the
outside you see
and then i move into the into the spiral
geometry
boom and
i find this and then
move further into this final geometry he
goes
hop here
oh
so
push push push
now if he already drives a little
then you can do a fade
he drives a little i can do a fade
if he drives a lot boom i gotta turn
and i would like you to drive a lot
because the fade doesn't work
so his strategy is very common it would
be the same one
for out here and he's pepper and me
peppery peppermint i would come in
and close the gap where i'm inside the
eye of the storm of his stripes
so i have the weapon
and he does not want to stay in my
weapon range
he has two choices he can be outside the
range of the hurricane
or he can be in the eye of the storm so
he had forward progress
right both and he's trying to smother
the weapon start trying to stop me from
using it again
otherwise i'm going to hit him again so
i'm just working on my transition
when we go slow what i'm out
i'm at weapon range and i keep the
strategy going
so he's really pressing on me go back
so this is going to be a turn he goes
and
if he only presses a little which isn't
a very good strategy on him like
so we'll find the outside don't come on
the inside
find the outside yield boom
[Music]
and you do all your cochlear protection
in the technique so it shouldn't be a
pain compliance it should be
a cookie projection
but for now both yield
won't find penny can leave it external
for now
boom boom
he goes on the outside
okay now just like the headlock
technique slip let's start working
energetically so
i going here and he goes and that energy
should go right into the uh
the focus projection line okay so
i go boom he goes and
then i don't really have to do nikki and
he doesn't
[Music]
in there i'm just holding it there so
boom
so
wow
[Music]
i'm going to take that grip away boom
okay